if you're like Minnie you get a new
phone every two years with some napkin
math you'll see this means about half of
your users will get a new phone this
year what happens when your user gets a
new phone Google Play will reinstall
your app and if you do nothing you'll
create a cold
welcome you'll show a blank login form
like they're a total stranger who has
never created an account no one enjoys
that and there's a few ways you can give
a warm welcome you can simplify login by
using Google sign-in smart lock and
autofill and you can easily move all of
your app settings to the new phone by
using auto backup you're probably
familiar with Google sign-in instead of
needing a username and password users
press a single button to securely log
them into your app with their gmail
account or any email address and if you
enable it they can even skip the button
by adopting Google sign and you can lift
registration and activation as well as
retention in your iOS web and Android
applications for users with a password
create a warm welcome with smart lock
for passwords smart lock is a password
manager and it'll offer to save users
passwords when they log in if they
decline it won't bug them again but if
they accept it securely stores their
password in the cloud your Android and
web applications can then fetch this
password programmatically so you don't
have to show them a login form smart
lock is backwards compatible from API 9
or Gingerbread in a case study one
company found a 20% reduction in login
related support requests by adding smart
lock and it really warms up the user
experience and reto adds the autofill
framework autofill works just like in
Chrome offering to save form content
when users enter their passwords or
other information as a developer you can
get ready by adding autofill hints and
setting up a digital asset link between
their website and Android application
this is a JSON file that you host on
your web server which allows autofill
services to share autofill data between
your web and Android app but how do you
move content that isn't behind a login
for example in Gmail we show welcome to
word from users you expect this to not
repeat on your news
and it doesn't we used our cloud backup
service to build this functionality and
because offering a warm welcome is
important Android users we offer to
Android apps for free auto backup saves
all of your apps changed files up to 25
megabytes nightly when your app installs
again the files are downloaded before it
launches restores aren't limited to play
installs and happen even when you side
load from Android studio or ADB to learn
more about configuring auto backup
including how to exclude files check out
the documentation on
developer.android.com remember auto
backup is not a good place to store
information like passwords or credit
card numbers and definitely not for
storing sensitive information like
medical records or financial data if
your app already has a different way to
transfer settings to a new phone check
to make sure you're transferring all of
the settings it's easy to forget a few
and users really want that warm welcome
thanks for watching I've included links
in the description for details about how
to integrate any of these features and
be sure to check out our previous video
on making your app autofill ready see
you next time
[Music]